hello and welcome to this video playing
st off 85 91 ok I played him quite often
recently I'm not sorry somehow somehow
more thinking of a Greenfeld ok so the
marker gone off I feel like I had this
recently against him very recently some
create Queen a3 is what I remember ok so
he it seems he wants to go at five pm
yeah I wonder if each for is actually
helpful here but ok probably is it
basically forces at five otherwise
that's h5 coming ok I'm taking I wonder
if Bishop h5 is actually a move or if
this is helpful i mean this is the thing
Bishop here this night coming to before
maybe the 92y for it should be an issue
oh it actually is an issue it can take
to form ok but I can take f5 first ok
where do I go with the Queen g2 hmm
that's an interesting question I mean he
has to address the pawn probably first
the hanging porn so night h5 is not a
move on no I don't think so oh that's
something I did not really have on the
radar ok I can start with this 94
threatening Knight f6 13 still Knight f6
he has to have this on the radar ok he
had but what now yeah probably just 32 g
6 technical or why do I have something
more powerful i can play something like
Queen d2 that's not bad my night is
excellent ok I think I'll go for this
some have to clean trade my position
must be must be good really ok um h5
this route f5 yeah okay
sure that this helps so let's go back
with the rook next most Kingda to look
to one root g one yeah that's a good
good position very good control I think
he cannot challenge my ear all night
this is a really really important and
not shedding challenging this or not
being able to challenge this is an issue
yeah here before is an interesting move
using this route a one-day eight
situation hmm not sure if it's helpful
though probably is I don't know not
entirely sure he definitely cannot take
this would give him this would allow an
absolutely deadly pin
okay well here interesting yeah I can
just go to you what I'll play b5 just ok
let's do this I mean the whole thing
this is a very one-sided position still
NTS problems moving Knight f6 37 for
example yes so watch now as good as it
looks I'm not quite sure I'm winning
this position
h5 roop g6 rookie sex with 1g six take
age 6 this kind of thing no cam is
preventing that okay can take here is
there something here some kind of tactic
maybe don't see it okay just go to your
phone
hmm ok check
okay let's put this on a dark square is
root g six leading to anything
not sure but I have many ways to make
slight improvement special f2h for as an
idea for where's he going now with this
rook rook look strapped to be honest
hmm it looks bad really bad okay
hmm so this is a win slime morning check
your bishop age form I'm not sure if
this is the win Luke back and f4 takes
everything should be seven hmm I had
it's hard to believe that this draws
maybe it does
with that use a huge space advantage you
would think that why should win but why
is he in playing the rook okay this that
maybe that's a draw maybe not
Bishop might get might get trapped if I
play Bishop d8 though that is something
something worth noting
and the bishop is trapped dirtiest
trapped after Bishop da de tus trapped
you know yes understood it as well I
actually have an idea here could be very
risky idea though check check black
resigns yeah metals and very convincing
I should just have some kind of normal
win there but I didn't find it yeah this
is right okay so where the engine this
is pretty brutal here wins with c5 but
this kind of technical wind should be on
this technical way should win this way
iaf for is winning ah ok that's a nice
one taking Bishop deform and then said
okay that's very convincing and I can go
F for here already but I wasn't sure why
I didn't see this move this is very
interesting interesting idea I was going
for a pure technical win and this might
be a draw
yeah the engine doesn't believe it it
says food says I'm winning but I don't
see how exactly ok let's go ahead a
couple of moves it always gives me plus
five or something yeah Bishop c7 I have
both are hanging in this case this in
this case I can just take that's stupid
he's not trapping it it's not trapping
anything he had to go here we had to
keep this and now I was only having this
in mind and this is indeed not good here
now my bishop is strapped so if he would
have played like and say here I have to
do something else but how I am i winning
their what is the engine giving and
gives this this this this I don't
understand the idea yet of the computer
it just shuffles around
I don't see a win either okay yeah I
could have taken but that was just due
to due to his blunder and I'm not sure
that this c5 idea was really great okay
but today it seems to win okay and this
was the way to when to go three and now
I'm yeah yeah I could have taken me six
but i only had 15 seconds so it wasn't
the ideal way to do it but it was
completely enough so then c5 is the
winning idea and I've found it that's
good even though i had easier easier
winds earlier okay thanks for watching